[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the relation of pure insight to the
naive consciousness of absolute being
now has a two-fold aspect on the one
hand pure insight is itself the same as
that consciousness on the other hand
this naive consciousness gives complete
liberty to absolute being as well as to
its parts in the simple element of its
thought and allows them to subsist there
and to be valid only as it's implicit
being and hence to be objectively valid
but in this implicit being it renounces
its own being for self insofar as
according to the first aspect this faith
is for pure insight in itself pure self
consciousness and has only to become
this explicitly for itself
pure insight has in this notion of self
consciousness the element in which
instead of false insight it realizes
itself
paragraph 544 is a very short one and
Hegel's just noting a few points for us
in this he talks about a two-fold aspect
of the relationship between two things
two things that were talked about in the
previous paragraphs one is this naive
consciousness which is you could say in
the narrative that's being talked about
where pure insight or the you might if
we want to personify at the person of
the Enlightenment is really the hero
then the naive consciousness is in a
certain respect the one who's being
rescued by the hero and being rescued
from the villains that we saw Hegel
talking about superstition priestcraft
and despotism
now how is pure insight going to relate
itself as a mode of of pure
consciousness something going beyond
culture to this naive consciousness
that's something that is really key to
the whole movement and you might say if
we want to use the term the culture the
new culture that's being produced of the
Enlightenment so Hegel tells us that the
relation of pure insight the connection
the way in which they're connected with
each other
to the naive consciousness of absolute
being or absolute essence if you like
Vaes and absolute the Vaes and now has a
two-fold aspect so on the one side he
says pure insight is itself the same as
that naive consciousness we'll come back
to that that's an important point
pure insight is not something that
according to the Enlightenment is only
available to a tiny little elite who
studied and studied and prepare
themselves for years and years and years
it should be something that is in theory
available to all so Peary insight ought
to be available to whoever has just a
regular consciousness now he says on the
other hand this
naive consciousness does something so
this is a way in which it's different
from pure insight which would never go
along with this sort of nonsense so what
does it do says this naive consciousness
gives complete liberty to absolute being
well that sounds pretty good as well as
to its parts in the simplest element of
its thought and allows them to subsist
there and to be valid only as its
implicit being it's it's being in itself
and hence to be objectively valid but in
the process he says it gives up its
being for self it's not self conscious
it's not related to itself through
consciousness instead it's being
captivated you might say by the content
of absolute being so we have a
transition here to you know having this
sort of objective stuff that it's
fascinated with and and you know which
things that's fascinated with is really
kind of contingent isn't it just depends
on what it happens to to run across
which parts of absolute being and so he
says okay it renounces its own being
herself and then insofar according to
the first aspect was the first aspect
this identity this faith now notice what
Hegel uses this term faith right faith
and pure insight are connected with each
other and this faith is for pure insight
in itself pure self consciousness and
has only to become this explicitly for
itself so insofar as this faith has to
become explicitly for itself
pure insight he says has in this notion
of self consciousness this idea that has
yet to be developed and will be
developed through the Enlightenment it
has in this notion the element wit in
which instead of false insight why do we
talk about false inside here well that
was what the you know priests were
preaching right that was what
superstition relied upon it realizes
itself he says so it's gonna be making
itself actual so Hegel is is not giving
us some sort of may
transformation here's just leading us
into the next section in which we're
going to get a really interesting
metaphor
since from this aspect both are
essentially the same and the relation of
pure insight takes place through and in
the same element the communication
between them is direct and their giving
and receiving is an unimpeded flow of
each into the other whatever wedges of
any sort may be driven into
consciousness it is in itself this
simplicity in which everything is
dissolved forgotten an unbiased and
which therefore is absolutely receptive
to the notion it is on this account that
the communication of pure insight is
comparable to a silent expansion or to
the diffusion say of a perfume in the
unresisting atmosphere it is a
penetrating infection which does not
make itself noticeable beforehand as
something opposed to the indifferent
element into which it insinuates itself
and therefore cannot be warded off only
when the infection has become widespread
is that consciousness which unheedingly
yielded to its influence aware of it for
though the nature of what consciousness
received into itself was simple and
imagine us with it yet it was also the
simplicity of an intro reflected
negativity which subsequently also
develops in keeping with its nature into
something opposed to it and thereby
reminds consciousness of its previous
state this simplicity is the notion
which is the simple knowing that knows
itself and also its opposite but knows
this opposite to be reduced to a moment
within it consequently when
consciousness does become aware of pure
insight the latter is already widespread
the struggle against it betrays the fact
that infection has occurred the struggle
is too late and every remedy adopted
only aggravates the disease for it is
laid hold of the marrow of spiritual
life that is the notion of consciousness
or the pure essence itself of
consciousness therefore - there is no
power in consciousness which could
overcome the disease because this is
present in the essence itself its
manifestations while still isolated can
be suppressed and the superficial
symptoms smothered this is greatly to
its advantage for it does not now
squander its power or show itself
unworthy of its real nature which
the case when it breaks out in symptoms
and single eruptions antagonistic to the
content of faith and to its connection
with the reality of the world outside it
rather being now an invisible and
imperceptible spirit it infiltrates the
noble part's through and through and
soon has taken complete possession of
all the vitals and members of the
unconscious idol then one fine morning
it gives its comrade a shove with the
elbow and bang crash the idol lies on
the floor on one fine morning whose noon
is bloodless if the infection is
penetrated to every organ of spiritual
life memory alone then still preserves
the dead form of the spirits previous
shape as a vanished history vanished one
knows not how and the new serpent of
wisdom raised on high for adoration has
in this way painlessly cast merely a
withered skin
paragraph 545 if we wanted to be a
little facetious we could give it the
title of Kant's famous book or actually
short little essay what is enlightenment
because Hegel is is telling us quite a
bit about what is going on in the
Enlightenment it's giving us kind of you
might say a bit of the inside scoop
about it we often have this this picture
to ourselves as people who that are very
distanced from it that it's more like
what Hegel was describing at the start
this you know we've got these brave
souls who are going against you know the
priesthood and despotism and and you
know the superstition of the people and
and writing treatises and getting in
everybody's face but but actually the
Enlightenment worked in a somewhat
different way and that's what Hegel is
going to talk about here in terms of
pure insight there's there's two master
metaphors running throughout this long
section one of them is that which we're
going to talk about in a bit of
diffusion something like you know the
diffusion of an odor or an essence
throughout an area but the other one
which is much more interesting has to do
with a sort of hollowing out and
emptying or even if you like a rotting
from within the things that it appears
that enlightenment is attacking the
Enlightenment can attack them precisely
because they have lost the dynamism that
they they would have had and why did
they lose it well it came about through
the effort of pure insight itself and so
Hegel has this wonderful line that has
taken from denis diderot x' ramos nephew
one of his great works i'm actually a
very big fan of Diderot myself because
he's a fun writer and then that was
really a story about the the culture of
the time and it almost appears in some
respects nihilistic
but what's what he's discussing there is
how
well I'll just read it to you he says
you know one fine morning it gives its
comrade a shove with the elbow and bang
crash the idol lies on the floor what's
the idol the idol is some sort of thing
that we take for you know having
absolute value giving meaning to our
life helping us orient ourselves it
might be the project it might be a
particular hierarchical relationship it
might be understanding our place in the
order of things or in history and any of
these things can become hollowed out in
that way it's not that they don't have
any meaning it's just that they don't
have as much meeting as they portray
themselves to they don't have meaning in
a very practical sense so let's let's
take up from the start with this text
what he's saying here he says from this
aspect both are essentially the same or
what are the both I think that we have
to interpret the both here as pure
insight and the naive consciousness that
was been talked about for the last
several paragraphs both are essentially
the same and he says the relation of
pure insight takes place through and in
the same element the communication
between them the communication between
the naive consciousness and pure insight
is going to happen through that that
element so you know the naive
consciousness doesn't really know itself
doesn't fully understand itself but you
could say it's primed to move on to
something greater to move on to a fuller
knowledge it has to become for itself as
Hegel says pure insight is almost
entirely for itself but it's not for
itself yet in a concrete way and part
because it lacks content and that's what
the naive consciousness is going to
provide it and so as faith and culture
so Hegel goes on and he says the
communication between them is direct
their giving and receiving there's a
back and forth here so it's not just
pure insight telling
naive consciousness hey dummy here's how
the world is or why don't you pay
attention to this it's also there's a
you know this is what we call a
dialectical process there's a dialogue
going on between the two of them a
communication the naive consciousness
has something to say to pure insight and
pure insight if it's really pure insight
has to learn from what the naive
consciousness has to say to it I mean
those are that you could say those are
the people on the ground who can tell
you about the conditions that that
people are living in so he says this
giving and receiving is an unimpeded
flow of each into the other almost
sounds as if they're going to modify
each other in the process now he says
whatever wedges of any sort may be
driven into consciousness it is in
itself this simplicity so we can make
distinctions but there really is a
simplicity here he says it's the
simplicity of the notion of the concept
that betrayed so he says it's the
simplicity in which everything is
dissolved forgotten and unbiased and
which is therefore is absolutely
receptive to the notion so let's pause
here what what are we talking about how
can we picture this to ourselves or
better yet how can we conceptualize it
wrap our heads around it so this is
happening at a in a certain not point
but period of history in the West where
you know Hegel is not talking about
these sorts of forces but think about
the role that literacy and the printing
press plays in this the capacity for
being able to discuss things back and
forth with each other to hear
perspectives that are not simply those
of not just the elite but but a certain
kind of elite being able to take on the
values that other people might might
bring up so I mean if you if you have a
peasant farmer who can go to market and
go into a car
shop and after he kicks the motto off of
his boots and plunks his money down
because he's actually read something
somebody might take him seriously when
he says you know all this fine talk that
you have is really great but it doesn't
really put any turnips in my larder or
help me figure out how to lessen the
taxes that those Nobles and churchmen
are demanding from me and keeping me
from actually filling my belly you know
I mean this sounds very prosaic but you
know that's the sort of thing where pure
insight might say well you've got a
point there right let's let's think
about this let's hash this out let's
talk about this so I think what Hegel is
talking about here partly is the
development of what is later come to be
called the public sphere in which all
these sort of ideas can circulate and
people can talk with each other and you
know become conscious so he says it's on
this account now here's the nice
metaphor that the communication of pure
insight is comparable to a silent
expansion you don't notice it going on
pure insight I mean it can be very
aggressive and an assertive and make a
lot of itself but that's probably gonna
be more like a false insight like
Hegel's been talking about real pure
insight just does its thing and it
spreads out throughout the entire room
or throughout the entire world like the
culture he says it's it's comparable to
a silent expansion or to the diffusion
say of a perfume in the unresisting
atmosphere he says it's a penetrating
infection which does not make itself
noticeable beforehand as something
opposed to the indifferent element in
which it insinuates itself and therefore
cannot be warded off there's no you know
gas detection equipment I used to have a
friend who specialized in in selling gas
detection equipment
we're really quite interesting I mean it
could save your life too if you find out
that carbon monoxide is accumulating in
a place or some some you know gas from
an industrial process that's that's very
nice there's nothing like that when it
comes to peer insight there's no canary
in the coal mine that tells you that
something's happening to the culture
instead things are diffusing into it and
pure insight is gradually seeping its
way into all of the institution's
all of the discourses it might take the
form of irony when it can't accomplish
much or desperation sometimes they'll
take on the form of critique or calls
for reform plans for how things can be
made better so he says only when the
infection has become widespread is that
consciousness which unheedingly yielded
to its influence aware of it and what
are we what are we talking about there
actually I know we I put culture down
here but I may as well have puts a state
power or wealth or the noble
consciousness associated with service of
state power and we also have faith now
what is pure inside doing in the course
of the early modern period leading us
into the Enlightenment it's gradually
permeating all these fears that of
culture and sometimes just asking
questions well why why do we have a
monarch and then you could justify it
you know write a philosophical trees
absolute monarchy is absolutely needed
but that starts to raise questions
doesn't it I mean this is one reason why
Hobbes who you would think would have
been highly favored by the you know
monarchists actually wasn't I mean he
the the king did you know have Hobbes
and his court after after things you
know got sorted out and there's a
restoration right
but they didn't enact Hobbes's political
theory he was really too radical he's
justifying more of that vision of the
sovereign than the the real sovereign
could could could endure and we can go
on and out of that you know youyou might
say that the pure insight is not always
hostile to faith or a culture it's
saying let me make you what you ought to
be you know faith don't you want to be
connected with God well then we have to
think about you know things morally and
evaluate how people are actually
behaving and you know point out when
when things aren't going the way that
they should or should we think about
these these texts and you know where did
these come from how do they get handed
down why do we have different copies
that don't always agree with each other
you know it's asking these questions
opening up these these realms of for
consciousness to go in and so you can
have people within the church for
example who are the greatest critics
within the church sometimes they get
kicked out right but that's how it
really develops it's not simply outside
forces saying this is all nonsense
superstition garbage get rid of it you
know you don't begin with the new
atheists in the middle of the
Enlightenment
instead it's churchmen themselves asking
questions probing saying oh wait a
second what about this similarly in
culture too so he goes on and he says
okay so the infection became widespread
that consciousness which unheedingly
yielded to its influence becomes aware
of it so the other forms of
consciousness the other shapes the
gestalt --an are becoming you might say
infected by pure insight and he says
through the nature of what consciousness
receipt although the nature of what
consciousness received into itself was
simple and homogeneous with it it was
also the simplicity as he says of an
intro reflected negativity which
subsequently also develops in keeping
with its nature into something opposed
to it so critique or the critical
negative aspect here introduces to these
things which seem to be you know okay
with themselves self identities new
opposition within them they become
divided against themselves and this is a
very important development so he says
here we go
reminds consciousness of its previous
state the simplicity the simplicity is
the notion which is the simple knowing
that knows itself in its opposite so
that the notion now is entering into
these historical shapes of consciousness
entering into institutions entering into
long-standing traditions and discourses
and gutting them hollowing them out
finding the the places where things
aren't entirely clear trying to clarify
them and in the process introducing some
hollowness to them so he says the the
notion is a simple knowing that knows
itself in its opposite but knows this
opposite to be reduced to a moment
within it so he says when consciousness
does become aware of pure insight the
latter is already widespread by the time
this is why you can't really hold back
cultural critique other than you knows
by killing everybody and you know
engaging in real repression but even
that doesn't work for that long once
pure insight is there Hegel Singh you
don't really have the option of just
squashing it you you have to grapple
with it you have to work your way
through it so he says the struggle
against it betrays the fact that the
infection has a
Hurd even among the ones who are posing
themselves in the narrative that they're
telling where they're the ones who
aren't infected by it they're the you
know naive consciousness in a different
respect that the honest consciousness
from from before they are infected by it
and we see this playing itself out over
and over and over again even in our
contemporary culture where you look at
you know conservatives and you're like
you're not really that conservative you
don't you don't even live up to your own
ideals or you you know the stuff that
you're saying if you if you looked at
what conservatives were saying 40 years
ago what you're saying is almost the
opposite of it what do you mean the
conservatives are in a certain sense the
new radicals the new counterculture and
you can look at liberals and
progressives you know and say you're not
as progressive as you seem to be some
respects you're actually quite
conservative you just want things to
stay the same just kind of moving along
in this direction and we can we can
delve into this in in many other
respects as well but you see this
happening over and over again this kind
of you know lining up of who people are
the characters in a narrative so he says
the struggle is too late every remedy
adopted only aggravates the disease
you're not going to beat pure insight at
its own game you're not going to be
smarter than it you better ride it out
and see where it goes so he says it's
laid hold of the marrow of spiritual
life that is the notion of consciousness
the pure essence itself of consciousness
and we might get less metaphysical than
that and say listen what happens here is
it does lay its hold on the marrow of
consciousness the particular shapes of
consciousness what makes them what they
are and says you're not what you think
you are so because there is no power in
consciousness that could overcome the
disease why because no matter what
remedy you attempt you're gonna have to
rely on pure insight and the notion to
bring it in to be effective this has
some very vast implications if we think
about our own time so he says that
because this is present in the essence
its man its manifestations while
isolating it can be suppressed and the
superficial symptoms smothered but this
plays into its hands he says this is
greatly to its advantage now it doesn't
squander its power show itself unworthy
of its real nature which is the case
when it breaks out into when it actually
takes concrete form in sync and symptoms
and single eruptions I mean you can try
to repress the critical movement the
critical aspect of pure insight you can
do that but then you make people
idealistic they don't they don't know
yet that the reformers and the
enlightened people are just jerks like
the rest of us they think they're heroes
and they you know secretly want to be
like them and we'll welcome them when
there's an opportunity you're better off
actually letting this run its course and
show itself to be just as full as far as
movement goes just as full of you know
egoistic jerks and posers as any other
movement is right if you if you try to
repress it or just try to say it's just
bad you know for example you know one
one of the things that's talked about a
lot today's post-modernism you know as
if somehow Derrida and Foucault or or
Deleuze or people like that or even you
know often read by the majority of the
public or even read much of the
University which is not the case as if
somehow they contaminated the culture
and now you know we we've lost you know
the Enlightenment and and modernity and
postmodernity is threatening us all with
ilysm and stuff like that and this is
such a caricature that when you say
stuff like that you almost make people
like me say maybe post-modernism isn't
so bad if these people are you know
think it's it's
bad and clearly they have no idea what
the hell they're talking about and you
know many other people might be
attracted to it similarly you don't you
can't win except by engaging your enemy
at their strongest points and you've got
to use the same weapons but that means
you've already lost at this point sort
of like the dialectic that we saw with
virtue in the way of the world Hegel
goes on and he says that being an
imperceptible and invisible spirit pure
insight infiltrates the noble parts
through and through and soon has taken
complete possession of the vitals and
members of the unconscious idol what are
we talking about faith here we're
talking about something that that Hegel
had said is in itself it does not have
self consciousness it has consciousness
of its particular content once pure
insight comes into faith seemingly to
make faith stronger it actually weakens
it so he this is where we get the one
fine morning he says on one fine morning
there's noone is bloodless if the
infection is penetrated into every organ
of spiritual life and then what we get
is a kind of museum existence for the
objects of faith he says memory alone
preserves the dead form of the spirits
vanished shaped a previous shape as a
vanished history vanished one knows not
how now this is perfectly compatible
with having a continuance of say
religious life going on you know but it
actually does become quite detached from
how most religious people are
understanding what's going on so faith
can become hollowed out from inside as
we see happen over and over and over
again this is what why in the West we
have you know all these interesting new
religious movements both within the
Protestant spectrum generally forming
new denominations often not meaning to
starting out as a reform movement and
you know saying we have to like
revitalize faith because it's it's
moribund it's become dead within the
Catholic an orthodox spectrum it happens
within and there are different movements
or orders or you know things going on
sometimes you know long-lasting
sometimes not so but the point is here
he says memory alone preserves the dead
form of the spirits previous shape and
the new serpent of wisdom raised on high
for adoration has in this way painlessly
cast a a withered skin away from itself
the the skin of an older understanding
of religion which was an understanding
of the human comportment in relation to
the divine so the enlightenment consists
to bring this all back so that the main
point in this diffusion that goes into
the institution's goes into the
traditions goes into the shapes of
consciousness and in some respect
colonizes them takes them over rendering
them unable to be what they previously
were
but this silent ceaseless weaving of the
spirit and the simple inwardness of its
substance spirit concealing its action
from itself is only one side of the
realization of pure insight its
diffusion consists not merely in the
fact that light goes together with liked
nor is its actualization merely an
expansion in which there is no
antithesis on the contrary the action of
the negative essence is no less
essentially a developed self
differentiating movement which being a
conscious act must give its moments a
definite manifest existence and must
appear on the scene as a sheer uproar
and a violent struggle with its
antithesis
paragraph 546 is now setting the scene
for a struggle that's going to happen in
the enlightenment but but a struggle
that's going to happen not only between
pure insight and faith or pure insight
and culture in terms of politics but
between pure insight in one sense you
might say in its Universal and pure
insight in its reality as its made
concrete so Hegel says that he talks
about a silent ceaseless weaving of the
Spirit and the simple awareness of its
substance very poetic their spirit
concealing its action from itself and
what is he referring to what's been
going on previously in this discussion
of diffusion into the culture and into
faith spirit is you know both sides and
doesn't quite know what's going on until
it becomes a consciousness of what has
taken place historically but that's not
all that's happening Hegel's saying all
right he says pure that the diffusion of
pure insight consists not merely in the
fact that light goes along with like
what was like and like in that case
spirit of the pure insight and the naive
consciousness nor is its actualization
merely an expansion which there's no
antithesis it was you know expanding
into other shapes of consciousness
colonizing them but what happens in the
process of doing so in the process of
becoming successful it's going to
generate its own opposition its own
antithesis so he says the action of the
negative essence which is the pure
insight is no less essentially developed
self differentiating moment which must
give its moments definite manifest
existence must appear on the scene as
sheer uproar in a violent struggle with
its antithesis now how is that violent
struggle going to take place well we're
going to see so just to set the scene
what we're going to do is move through
what it is that that that pure insight
is generating how does it become
concrete how does it
have a shape of its own in the world and
then what does that look like
does it really live up to its own ideals
or does it become something that becomes
its own enemy this is looking far far
down the line to things like you know
radical freedom and the terror absolute
freedom in the terror but we don't have
to go quite that far
yeah just think about institutions where
we have people engaged in critique and
how critical they also often become of
those who actually do take a stand on
that basis
you